はじめ）え、結構最強レベルの霧じゃない？
は）信号のライトがでかく見える
後輩・は）ｗｗｗｗｗ
後）ここ？え？入ってけってことですかこれ？
は）ここを左ですねー　うん
後）しとどの窟に？　は）そう
は）１０ヶ月ぶりかー
は）しとどの窟という場所にきております
は）湯河原町にある源頼朝が隠されたとされる洞窟らしいです
後）おおお！ほー
は）とりあえず首のないお地蔵さんを見たらもう詰みだと思っていただければ…
後）アウト？　は）アウトです
は）逆にそこさえ見なければワンチャンドン勝狙えるんじゃねーくらいの
後）確かに　は）感覚でございますｗ
後）はははははｗｗ
は）ペロン
は）うわなんで　不意打ち×４
後）ねえ”ぇ”ぇ”ーーーもうさ
は）はははｗそんなさーｗトンネル
後）もうやだあ”あ”""あ”あ”本当に
は）通行止めですかね　ここから先は
後）待って、はじめさんめっちゃなんかやばいもう
後）え、え、、え
は）待って本当に怖い
後）え、これどこに駐車するんすか
は）こっから多分降りていった方かいいっすね
後）ヒカキンです
（カチッ）
（カチッカチカチカチカチ）
（カチカチ）
後）じゃはじめさんよくないからね　一回、一回ちょっと出てみてくださいよ
は）無理だ絶対鍵かけるじゃん俺もう知ってるよ
（ガチャ）
（バタン）
は）いや、ハンパねーなここ　どうするこれ本当に怖いんだよ久しぶりで
（ガチャ）
（バタン）
（カチャ：車の鍵を閉めるはじめん）
（ドンッ）
は）くぅーｗはっｗｗｗ
（ドンドンドン　コンコンコン）
は）あははははｗあははははははははｗ
（カチャ）
（ドンッ）
は）うわあああああああびっくりしたあ
は）ダメだ行こう！　後）はい
は）俺たちかれこれ１５分ここにいるからねｗ
後）あっあっあ！　は）おいおいおい大丈夫か？
は）ばかばか
は）どうした？どうした？どうした？
後）カギ、カギ
は）カギじゃないか
後）ん？待って待ってえ？なんで？
は）何してる？何してる？
後）ん？ん？
後）お待ちください　は）はい
後）え？　は）何してる？
後）ちぎれた　は）もう？
後）え、ポケットの中で　え、ポケットの中にカギ入れて今
は）じゃこっちももう外照らしにあてるわ
は）まじめにYouTuberやるんだよなこういう時だけ
は）待ってこれすごいな
後）いや、はじめさん見てよほら
ポンポンポンポンポンポンと
は）ほら泣いてんだよ　見える？
後）ほんとだ光ってる
は）なんで泣いてんの？
後）なか、泣かないでー
後）お札割れてんじゃん
は）おいこれさお札割ったの誰だよーふざけんじゃねーよまじで
後）ねぇ”ぇ”ーーーまじかよ
は）フッははははｗねぇ怒んないでｗ
後）ほんとに
は）あー倒れてんねー
後）なにやってんすかもう本当に風！
は）これ誰倒したの
は）まじで壊れてんじゃん
後）ねぇ”ぇ”ーもう
は・後）だって
は）壊れてるんだよね　後）直してからきます
は）直せそうかな俺たちで　後）無理だなぁ
♪軽快な音楽〜
後）こっからがししど
は）こっから？ え、こっからがししどなの？
は）今までじゃあ何？練習だったてこと？
は）大丈夫？　後）大丈夫ですよ
後）ちょっと滑るので足元確認して　は）OK OKー
は）俺ガンガンいっていい？　後）はい
（タッタッタッタッタッタ）
は）ねー　早くおいで
は）うわっ　ま、待ってやばい
後）ねーもう
後）ねぇヤバイここはでも
は）もうちょっともうヤバイねヤバイね
後）本当にヤバイ本当にヤバイ
は）もう行こもう行こ
後）帰りがあるんすよ帰り
は）いや、ほんともう無理もう無理戻ろ戻ろ戻ろ
後）ねー早歩きしないでまじでもー
は）ごめんまさやくんごめんね
は）怖いんだはじめん　後）ねー